d'ordinaire on inaugure les créations
ici c'est une suppression qui est
célébrée celle de ce passage à niveau
remplacé par un pont routier au dessus
de la voie ferrée s'il n'y a que dix
trains par jour sur cette ligne
brétigny la membrolle sur choisille ce
sont douze mille véhicules dont plus
d'un tiers de camions qui transitent sur
cette route il n'y a pas eu d'accident
mortel mais il ya eu des accidents
matériels graves ou se rappeler que ce
passage à niveau étaient dans une courbe
dangereuse ange léger dévers
donc il ya eu une multitude d'accidents
et on a eu beaucoup de chance parce
qu'il ya eu 2 pas eu de dommages
corporels définitive sert pas de décès
en filigrane le député fait allusion à
des drames comme celui d'allinges en
haute savoie où sept enfants sont morts
sur un passage à niveau
nous n'avons pas eu d'accident de ce
type mais bien évidemment un accident ne
prévient pas cette strate était toujours
là et cette crainte a à motiver
justement
les travaux engagés pour aboutir à la
suppression des points les plus
dangereux engagé dans la sécurisation
des passages à niveau l'état avait
identifié ce lieu comme étant à risque
dès 1998 mais il ne l'a inscrit dans sa
liste prioritaire qu'en 2008
je pense que les premiers passages à
niveau qui ont été traitées sont des
passages qu'elle y avait eu des
accidents réels constatés alors que là
on a eu on a pas eu d'accident grave sur
ce passage il ya eu des petits accidents
mais apple d'accidents graves et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est voilà que ce
n'ait été mis dans la liste qu'en 2008
entre les concertations les études et
les travaux il aura fallu attendre 11
ans avant de remplacer le passage à
niveau par ce pont routier pour un coût
de 8 millions et demi d'euros au niveau
régional
il reste désormais un troisième et
dernier point noir à supprimer situé
dans le loir et cher
les travaux devraient débuter cette
année